nous sommes donc toujours en émission
spéciale un bienvenue à vous si vous
nous rejoignez après donc cette annonce
d'une intervention russe en ukraine
cette intervention qui a été annoncé par
vladimir poutine à la télévision russe
était ce matin à l'aube le chef du
kremlin qui a donc autorisé cette
opération spéciale militaire dans toute
l'ukraine pas seulement dans l'est des
explosions ont été entendues dans
plusieurs villes kiev mais aussi
marioupol cramatte osc cette ville dans
l'est de l'ukraine qui sert de quartier
général à l'armée ukrainienne mais aussi
à kharkiv la deuxième ville du pays et
aussi à odessa sur la mer noire on va
tout de suite prendre la direction de
kiev nous attend notre envoyé spécial
clovis casali bonjour clovis les sirènes
vont retentir ce matin dans la capitale
ukrainienne des explosions ont été
entendues qu'est ce qui se passe
actuellement sur place
des sirènes ont retenti pour inviter à
les ukrainiens à se mettre à l'abri et
oui dès l'aube un peu avant l'aube mais
mais bien des explosions ont retenti un
peu partout dans le pays et aussi à qui
rêve en tout cas on les a entendus ici
dans pleins en plein dans le centre de
kiev à la place maïdan des explosions
qui ondule donc eu lieu a priori à
l'extérieur de la ville notamment au
niveau de l'aéroport des explosions donc
et c'est un réveil difficile pour les
ukrainiens qui ont entendu à ces
explosions qui ont pris peur pour
certains un vent de panique pas dans le
centre ville de vie centre-ville où je
me trouve qui est quasi désert a pas des
forces de l'ordre et des forces de
sécurité est déployé mais dans les
autres quartiers de kiev où la
population a s'est rendu en masse dans
les supermarchés dans les stations
service dans des supermarchés on nous
racontait d'ailleurs qu' ils ne prennent
plus les cartes bleues les cartes de
crédit pareil pour les stations essence
où elles sont aussi en rupture de stock
on a pu quand même parlé avec des jus
craignant ainsi dans le centre ville
entre inquiétude et incompréhension très
très déçu de la situation de la tournure
des événements je vous propose tout de
suite d'écouter quelques ukrainien
ça y est la partir de 6h ce matin comme
monde a commencé à s'activer a tenté de
quitter kiev mais il y avait énormément
de monde et c'est impossible de fuir
l'ukraine en ce moment la barre des
canaux l'aft
bref vous savez si la guerre commence
ici tout le monde va se battre moi par
exemple je ne laisserai pas ma maison à
d'autres gens
clovis casali le président zelensky a
appris de nouveau la parole tout à
l'heure on l'a suivi en direct sur
france 24
il appelle au calme il a invité les
ukrainiens même à à prendre les armes
les ukrainiens à prendre les armes et
une loi avait été votée
ces derniers jours pour permettre
justement aux ukrainiens de pouvoir se
défendre ceux de pouvoir prendre des
armes si besoin est et donc ces derniers
jours et bien les ukrainiens notamment à
kiev se sont rendus dans les armureries
pour être prêt à se défendre si les
russes arrivent jusqu à kiev est aussi
dans d'autres parties du pays c'est dire
à la crainte l'inquiétude qui règne ici
dans le pays des ukrainiens qui sont
donc prêts à repousser l'envahisseur
russe la russie qui a donc mené une
opération des opérations coordonnées de
grande envergure durant la nuit et à
l'aube et qui continuent actuellement le
président ukrainien bien sûr qu'ils
cherchent à rassurer sa population à
garder un certain morale à dire au
peuple ukrainien que le pays vaincra
c'est en tout cas son message et en même
temps un message de prudence en appelant
les ukrainiens déjà à quitter la russie
mais aussi à rester chez eux ici en
ukraine l'ukraine qui a rompu ses
relations diplomatiques avec la russie
et tout à l'heure le porte-parole de le
porte-parole de la présidence
ukrainienne a déclaré bien que 4 40
soldats ukrainiens avaient péri dans les
combats mais aussi une dizaine de civils
et des dizaines de civils blessés
on a donc entendu des explosions ce
matin très tôt est aussi tout à l'heure
une forte détonation nous étions juste à
côté est ici propre l'est près de la
place midane et des forces de sécurité
nous ont demandé de nous retirer de
cette position pour des raisons de
sécurité mais bien sûr pour l'instant à
meydan et notamment dans le centre ville
de kiev c'est calme mais ce n'est pas le
cas dans le reste du pays